as many of you know there are a lot of
fake quotes circulating out there on the
internet and those attributed to Marcus
tulus Cicero the great Roman orator
politician and philosopher are really no
exception and we find a kind of mixed
bag of these quotes having to do with
their origin some of them are
originating from what we can factiously
call fanfiction as you'll find out
others coming from other authors in
Antiquity and some much more recent so
we are going to look at 10 fake quotes
particularly egregious ones that are
often attributed to Cicero quite
uncritically by many people and then
shared and re-shared so let's take a
look at the first one the spirit is the
true self the spirit the will to win and
the will to excel are the things that
endure now there is a little bit of that
that does sound a bit like cisero
although he never says the spirit or the
mind the Anam is the true self and as it
turns out where does this quote
originate from it's very close to us in
time and in my case actually in space
because it comes from the famous NFL
coach of the Green Bay Packers Vince
Lombardi who says the spirit the will to
win and the will to excel are the things
that endure so it's a almost direct
quote right from Lombardi
himself now we move move on to another
very very famous quote that actually
turns out to be a misquotation of cisero
a room without books is like a body
without a soul and now there is a little
tiny grain of let's call it very
similitude if not truth to this because
we find out that um cisero did in fact
say something like since tyo organized
my books a mind seems to have been added
to my house but here's where knowing
some Latin is very helpful mind is
animus soul is Ana so they are not the
same term at all and the Roman thinkers
did distinguish those two as it turns
out where does this quote come from uh
it comes from a biography of cisero
titled the life of Marcus tulus Cicero
by William fory who says referring to
this line that it seemed as if his house
had got a soul so foresight seems to be
very Loosely paraphrasing here and
getting things wrong in some respect
taking some Liberties and then it gets
into the public Hopper and becomes
attributed to CIS
as such and this really does set the
stage well for some of the other fake
quotes that
follow so here is the first of three
that we're going to be looking at why
because they are all from the same
author and that author is not cisero a
nation can survive its fools and even
the ambitious but it cannot survive
treason from within an enemy at the
gates is less formidable for he is known
and Carries His Banner openly but the
traiter moves amongst those within the
gate freely as Sly Whispers rustling
through all the alleys heard in the very
Halls of government itself now this is
from Taylor Caldwell a fairly recent
author who wrote a novel that has cisero
as a main character called a pillar of
iron and apparently it was quite a
popular novel and a lot of people
mistakenly assumed that the things that
were being said by the character cisero
in the novel are what Cicero himself
actually said much as if we were to
watch uh the Gladiator and to take as
people have fake quotes from Marcus
arelius that are actually part of a
movie script this is the eventually
fanfiction of a certain sort and
Caldwell probably didn't intend for the
words she's putting in Cicero's mouth to
be taken as if they are what Cicero said
but many many people have done that
subsequently here's another quote from a
pillar of iron if our lives are
endangered any and every method of
protecting ourselves is morally right
now not only is that a quote that isn't
from cisero it actually goes against
something that cisero says in uh one of
his very important Works called on
duties where he is discussing the duties
that we owe to enemies and so he's not
Cicero doesn't think that any and every
method of protecting ourselves is
morally right as a matter of fact he
condemns that so probably Taylor didn't
understand Cicero all that well in her
novel and she certainly depicts him
poorly this is a quote that gets used
quite a bit by people on the right to
justify aggression and violence against
those who they perceive as their
enemies our third quote which is
actually originating once again from
Taylor Caldwell's a pillar of iron but
takes on an interesting life of its own
runs like this the budget should be
balanced the treasury should be refilled
public debt should be reduced the
arrogance of official Dum should be
tempered and controlled and the
assistance to foreign lands should be
curtailed lest Rome become bankrupt
people must again learn to work instead
of living on public assistance so this
one actually wound up getting attributed
wrongly to Marcus tulus Cicero in the
Congressional Record because a
representative uh AO passman gave a
short speech in which he quoted it and
apparently Ronald Reagan also referred
to it when he was California governor
and was citing bits and pieces of it as
well but it's actually coming from
Caldwell's book so once again we see a
quote take on an entire life of its own
this one given a
veneer of respectability and you know
false Truth by having poorly educated
public officials citing it as if it was
a genuine quote by
Cicero here we have another thing that
Cicero not only didn't say but wouldn't
have said the closer the collapse of an
Empire the crazier its laws now why do I
say he wouldn't have said that well to
begin with Cicero is living most of his
life in the end of the Roman Republic
not during the Roman Empire he does get
to see the beginning
of uh you know the Roman Empire you can
say and will in fact perish due to some
of the power struggles that are taking
place but he's not looking at it in some
sort of
historical point of view where he can
say yes the Empire's been around for a
long time and like other Empires you
know it's got all sorts of crazy laws he
was there at the very beginning and so
he wouldn't be saying this now where
does this actually come from the closest
thing that we have is tacitus in his
annals where he says the more corrupt
the state the more numerous the laws
crazy laws isn't something that cisero
probably would have been saying to put
laws down he probably would have been
saying there's too many or they're
poorly organized or something along
those
lines we have another quote here this
time it's actually attributable to
another ancient author study carefully
the character of the one you recommend
lest their misconduct bring you shame
now this is not something that is anti-
ciceronian but it just doesn't happen to
be said by cisero we know that because
it actually is said by Horus in his
letters so you know it's not something
that cisero couldn't ever have said
given the other the things that we do
know he has said but in point of fact we
know it's not by him and so people
probably shouldn't be attributing to
cisero something that is clearly by
another author we have here another
quote by the same author not Cicero but
Horus live as brave men and if Fortune
is a verse front its blows with brave
heart now you know not a bad sentence
ment at all but it isn't
ciceros and you know why shouldn't we
attribute to the person who actually set
it the quip that belongs to them here we
have quite a longish set the six
mistakes of men and this gets attributed
to cisero but isn't actually by him so
six mistakes mankind keeps making
Century after Century believing that
personal gain is made by crushing others
worrying about things that cannot be
changed or corrected insisting that a
thing is impossible because we cannot
accomplish it refusing to set aside
trivial preferences neglecting
development and refinement of the Mind
attempting to compel others to believe
and live as we do and you know maybe
there's something quite true about this
but it's not truly attributed to Cicero
and and in fact nobody did attribute it
to Cicero until around the 1940s because
before that they knew that it came from
a book written by a guy named Bernard
maor turns up in 1914 and it's called
secrets of personal culture and business
power that you know that's a sort of
common genre of literature at the time
sort of self-help book and interestingly
it turns out that there were seven
mistakes in life and they just didn't
put all of them into that list so we get
six that nowadays people attribute to
Cicero our final quote is quite a funny
one in multiple respects times are bad
children no longer obey their parents
and everybody is writing a book so
there's a long history to this and I'm
not going to go through the entire thing
you can go online and look it up quite
easily in quote investigator so there
was this guy a professor of philosophy
George Thomas White Patrick who wrote a
article called the new optimism and he
said that he saw this ancient tablet in
the city of istan buul in a museum and
it was supposedly uh from you know know
3,800 years before Christ and it said
some of these words on it and then what
we get is that people are are repeating
this story over and over and over again
and by the
1920s we get a reworking of the story
and it's uh WR Moody the son of the
famous evangelist who said says that um
the tablet says our Earth is degenerate
in these later days there are signs the
world is speedily coming to an end
children no longer obey their parents
every man wants to write a book and so
how does this become cisero after a
while people start attributing a
shortened version of the saying to
cisero it's not quite clear how but it
would be a weird thing for cisero to be
saying this especially since he in fact
complains that people are not doing
enough writing at least philosophical
writing in Latin in the prefaces of many
of his books so you know not only
wouldn't ciso say this but it's also
something that we know tracks from uh
not earlier writers but later writers in
the 20th century so to bring yet another
fake quotes video to a close I'm going
to give you the same advice that I
always do you should always exercise
healthy suspicion or skepticism if a
quote doesn't tell you where it's
actually coming from you probably should
be a little bit on guard against it and
if you see a quote and it sounds really
good and you think that it's something
you'd like to repost if it doesn't
actually say what text it comes from
don't repost it you're just adding to
the problem rather than making things
good and you can say oh well it seems
true or it's a true sentiment you're
doing damage to our you could say our
Collective mind on the internet you know
the other thing demand sources when
people post a quote if it sounds too
good to be true say what book did that
actually come from and sometimes people
will say oh I don't know I just saw it
and it looked pretty cool so I posted it
and then you can say well it's probably
a fake quote then and check out
sententia antiqui they're very good with
discussions of fake quotes and then
there's also of course quote
investigator another great site for
finding out which quotes are true and
which quotes are falsely attributed to
people so that that's it for this one
that's 10 fake quotes attributed falsely
to Marcus tulus
Cicero